I'm Patrick made of your host 'value
tainment and today i want to tell you a
story about Horace grand Scottie Pippen
in a cat Horace Grant Scottie Pippen in
a cat listen if you haven't read the
book the life by Michael Jordan or
audiobook you gotta listen to talkin we
put a link up here with the picture on
the video and as well on the link on the
bottom so you can get it and buy for
yourself this is an incredible book to
read because there's so much insight on
the mind of the greatest basketball
player of all time so let me taste or
about what happens so this is this is
the part about leadership development
and being too soft and without working
on your mental and emotional toughness
of any game you're in you're not gonna
elevate to the next level and there's
always somebody that's gonna challenge
you to elevate so Horace Grant and
Michael Jordan or and Scottie Pippen
they're coming out of college and they
get drafted and they go to the Chicago
Bulls okay
the Chicago Bulls have the best player
in the NBA Michael Jordan everybody and
also Michael Jordan is Scottie and
Horace become best of friends they
become best friends they party together
you know they're they're partying in
Chicago to get any time they're
traveling they're going out there so
they have money it's the first time
they're experiencing all the fame and
all this other stuff and Jordan is
getting very annoyed with them so it's
Phil Jackson so one day they're in
practice and they notice Scottie Pippen
is in terror and Horace Grant is in
there and Jordan says to Phil Phil says
to Jay hey where's Scott Ian and Horace
and in Phil says well wait a minute
what's going on they take Oh Scottie
called in because he couldn't play today
why not because it's can't died today
Phil says is what it's can't beg today
Phil calls and says get your butt over
here to practice what I mean you can't
die today
so Scottie comes to practice with Horace
and Horace you know looks at everybody
and says hey yeah can we all give a
moment of silence to a Scotties cat
because to mourn for the loss of his cat
and Jordan purely snaps
everybody he completely snaps at
everybody and he says what do you mean
Chad and he goes that Phil Phil tells
them what can't what moment of silence
and Jordan completely I mean I don't
want to use the words you got to read
the book to see what Jordan tells these
guys he completely goes off at him and
he says Phil we're gonna win a
championship with these two softies what
they can't even handle something like
that happening what are you gonna do
when a relative passes away what are you
gonna do when the bigger challenges
happens in your life what are you gonna
do when all this kind of crap takes
place in your personal life we are in
this image of basketball every day
someone wants to write about us
someone's getting pregnant someone's
doing this you can't handle a cat how
are you gonna handle the bigger problems
so Jordan started getting to the point
where he felt a little bit uncomfortable
about the fact that maybe he does not
have the right teammates to go out there
and win championships listen to what
happens fast forward a year two years
later during the playoffs playing the
Pistons Scotty's father passes away
Scotty doesn't come to one of the games
he has headaches all this stuff they
lose a series they come back and Phil
realizes in order for them to build a
team that can win a championship to face
against the Pistons Phil needs to
develop a stronger mentally and
emotionally tough leaders because Jordan
will not stop pushing and challenging
them on how soft they are in order to
win a championship because nobody wins a
championship without some incredible
life-changing events that happens that's
difficult whether you go to Tony Dungy
and the book quiet strength when his son
passes away Arnold Schwarzenegger was
going to mr. Olympia when his brother
and his father passed away if you go to
anybody that's ever done anything big
Teddy Roosevelt who lost his first two
wives and his kids and he became a
president if you go to anybody whoever
ends up competing at the highest level
they eventually have to learn how to
become mentally and emotionally tough
and if you're in a team building
business where you have a staff you have
a team of a group of agents
if you don't mentally and emotionally
drill for will of your team over skill
constantly when hard
show up you're gonna realize you have a
very soft team if you don't talk about
it the tough times will definitely
reflect how soft of a team you've built
versus how tough of a team you built
this doesn't mean you don't mourn this
doesn't mean you don't cry this doesn't
mean you don't get emotional this
doesn't mean you're not in pain this
doesn't mean you're not upset this
doesn't mean you're not you know
emotionally getting furious this doesn't
mean you're not going through any of
that stuff but it still means you have a
life to live you still have other things
that's going on you still have
responsibilities you still got to rise
up if you want to be considered a leader
leaders have no choice but to rise up
and step up and make sure they still
deliver during times of crisis so the
story about Pippen Horace Grant and the
cat told in the life of Michael Jordan
is one of many stories that you'll read
about why this guy is known as the
greatest competitor in greatest
basketball player and possibly the
greatest athlete of all time there is so
much to be learn about this guy's mental
and emotional toughness when his father
passed away when his family passed away
when all of those things that happen
with this guy you'll realize why he is
who years it's my message of the week to
you and please if you have any questions
and comments comment on the bottom if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
be sure to subscribe to this channel as
well thanks for watching